la bagnole bonsoir alors vous êtes le
petit fils de marcel pagnol et on a le
plaisir de vous recevoir l'occasion de
la parution de cette grande biographie
chez flammarion de jean-jacques gillot
blanc pagnol inconnu ah c'est vrai qu'on
a l'impression de connaître pagnol mais
encore beaucoup de choses à découvrir et
vous allez nous y aider alors d'abord
savoir marcel pagnol est mort en 74 il
est mort à 77 ans et le pagnol c'est
l'enfant d'aubagne c'est la provence
devenu universel et pour le grand public
ça reste à la fameuse trilogie marius
fanny césar
au cinéma il a d'abord été un grand
homme de théâtre on va voir que la
plupart des films qu'il a tournés ont
d'abord été des pièces de théâtre et de
d'énormes succès ota
et puis il est l'écrivain des souvenirs
d'en france a alors vous vous êtes celui
qui gère l'oeuvre de marcel pagnol qui
est considérable et d'ailleurs vous
publiez et c'est la première fois et
c'est un peu étonnant il n'y a jamais eu
de beaux livres sur marcel pagnol
donc ce sera marcel pagnol l'album d'une
vie c'est flammarion on retrouvera des
documents privés où on trouvera bien sûr
des photos graphiques
c'est vous qui allez en parler nicolas
pagnol face au miroir dites nous votre
passion pour votre grand père marcel
pagnol
il est il est carrément marquée par le
cinéma par l'adp par sa naissance ou par
naissance du cinéma il est née le même
jour que le que le cinéma en 1895
quelques kilomètres de là le cinéma la
ciotat et lui partait de la ciotat
justement sa mère monte à aubagne pour
pour accoucher son père est directeur
d'école instituteurs sa mère est
couturière il a une éducation somme
toute très classique
très très stricte après étonnant c'est
que marcel pagnol aura un phare sera
berger qui sera berger toute sa vie oui
le petit paul qui apparemment est tombé
éperdument amoureux des collines bien
plus que marcel et qui a décidé d'y
vivre
mais il faut dire aussi que le petit
paul avait une maladie et donc ils
avaient beaucoup de mal à vivre en
société dont killer il vivait dans les
collines et
malheureusement marcel le perdra en 1932
en essayant de le faire opérer le faire
soyez et il perd sa maman très jeune
augustine il âgé de 15 ans et cette
perte va le marquer toute sa vie
et d'ailleurs je vois que son plus beau
cri d'amour pour sa mère ses dents dans
la gloire de mon père l'a lorsqu'il
explique qu'il montait à la bastide
neuve il parle des modelés si fragile de
de sa mère il en parle comme d'une
enfant c'est assez émouvant où est-ce
qu'on peut parler sa vie amoureuse qui
est compliqué qui commence assez tôt oui
mais je crois que c'était un homme qui
aimait beaucoup les femmes il en avait
beaucoup il a eu beaucoup d'enfants
aussi tout ça avant guerre avant qu'il
ne rencontre jacqueline ma grand mère se
stabilise à la cinquantaine mais il a
une vie amoureuse très tumultueuse oui
très très tumultueux orane demazis qui
était qui était une actrice très
importante et qui a été une partie
amoureuse et tumultueuse de sa vie oui
il la rend compte chez dulin je crois
1923 à paris et elle va lui faire
découvrir le monde théâtral parisien lui
petit petit marseillais qui arrive à la
capitale et grande histoire d'amour qui
va naître et tout de suite il va il a
pensé à elle pour pour ses premiers
grands rôles féminins comme par exemple
dans jazz en 1926 et qui par la suite
marius fanny sens il faut savoir qu'il
est marié il est marié à simone qui va
refuser pendant très très longtemps de
divorce et ça va être une
un combat acharné acharnée elle
acceptera le divorce en 1944 marcel
puisse épouser jacqueline je ne pourrais
pas vous dire pourquoi il ya tremblement
de terre c'est eux passent on né en 1928
et cette pièce va avoir un succès et
c'est peut-être même la pièce qu'elle de
plus de succès de toute l'oeuvre de
marcel pagnol et c'est une pièce dont on
dit qu'elle a été plus joué encore que
cyrano oui elle est énormément joué
d'abord elle a été créée à berlin avant
d'être monté à paris au théâtre des
variétés et tout de suite c'est une
carrière internationale
alors alors que c'est pas les valeurs de
topaze ou même l'intriguent ne
correspond pas à ce que l'on sait
aujourd'hui où ce que l'on aime de
marcel pagnol c'est à dire ce qui vient
venir juste après c'est à dire marius
qui semble être
voilà qui semble être marcel pagnol
incarner petits détails
marcel pagnol n'aimez pas la mer mais on
vous détestez la mer ils avaient ils
peur bleue de l'eau je crois qu'il a
pris le bateau deux fois de nos trois
fois dans sa vie la première fois pour
aller voir le premier film parlant à
londres sur l'humain et les deux autres
fois pour aller voir son ami quino en
corse mais tous à 40 ans d'intervalle
non justement on pourra peut-être parler
de sa découverte du cinéma parlant
il faut dire qu'on en 1930 mais que
marcel pagnol c'est un pour tout le
monde c'est un dramaturge et quand il va
se lancer dans le cinéma parlant il va
être considéré comme un renégat comme un
traître on va lui demander de reverser
ses droits d'auteur aux bonnes oeuvres
de la hesse a cédé les directeurs de
studios de cinéma muet le considère
comme quelqu'un de dangereux parce que
je n'étais pas préparé au parlant et
et marcelo lui s'est retrouvé d'un coup
tout seul et heureusement il a rencontré
quelqu'un de chez paramount bob kane et
ils ont sympathisé et bob kane au bout
d'un moment accepté de produire marius
parce que dans la foulée il va faire
famille parce qu'il écrit une rapidité
incroyable
oui mais c'est à dire c'est long
volterra le directeur du théâtre de
paris pour été créée marieuse qui lui
dit écoute c'est un succès phénoménal je
crois qu'ils étaient la deuxième ou la
troisième saison vif absolument une
suite et donc marcel est parti je crois
chez chez leone pendant un été
écrire écrire fanni en même temps ou
juste après qu'il ait tourné marius donc
en 1931 alors un autre aspect de marcel
pagnol qui est très important c'est
qu'il avait le souci de gagner son
indépendance par rapport au milieu du
cinéma et donc il a créé sa première
parce que l'on a créé plusieurs
compagnies de cinéma donc cédé fils
marcel pagnol
oui mais c'est un trait de caractère
chez lui déjà quand bob kane il propose
de produire marieuse bob kane il veut
lui imposer des grandes vedettes du
cinéma et marcel dit néanmoins je veux
mes acteurs de théâtre il arrive à les
imposer
et lorsqu'il tombe sur les comptes de la
contenu de la paramount qu'il voit les
sommes investies et les sommes récoltées
et il se dit y'a pas de raison que je
monte pas mam a sauté de production
d'autant plus que paramount avait
produit topaze avait acquis les droits
de taupe avec marcel n'était pas du tout
d'accord avec l'adaptation qui avait été
fait donc il s'est dit je monte masqué
de production premièrement je serai
libre de créer comme je l'entends de
faire les adaptations de mes oeuvres
comme je l'entends et puis en même temps
je pourrai gagner assez d'argent pour
continuer à produire des films alors ya
un épisode tout à fait étranger la mort
de son frère paul
et il ya une coupure rumeur qui a couru
moment de son enterrement qui a été un
enterrement extrêmement discret et qu'on
a cru se crème pas secret du tout c'est
à dire que paul donc été malade
marcel a voulu faire soigner en belgique
et suite à l'opération paul est décédé
je pense que tout simplement mars elle
s'est sentie responsable de ce décès
donc donc on va monter une fable en
disant que c'était lui le véritable
auteur avait des principales oeuvres de
marcel pagnol
non il n'est absolument pas paul qui a
écrit marius fanny césar d'ailleurs
marcel après a continué à écrire alors
que paul avait disparu mais vous savez
quand à un auteur aussi jeunes
acquièrent une telle renommée un tel
succès auprès du public est toujours des
gens de mauvaises langues pour essayer
de le salir
d'autant plus qu'il allait à l'encontre
décrite des critiques et les théoriciens
du cinéma de l'époque et qu'il avait
créé un magazine les cahiers du film qui
dépend des pour défendre ses propres
théories donc ils s'affrontaient avec
ces gens là ils et c'était une guerre
vraiment mais dur où il avait il avait
un ensemble d'activités qui couvrait
tous les secteurs de l'activité
cinématographique et d'ailleurs il faut
le dire il est considéré comme pour par
les italiens comme le père du
néoréalisme c'est à dire que c'est lui
qui a tourné pour la première fois en
son direct lumière en décors naturels
c'est lui le premier
marcel tu es quelqu'un d'indépendant de
libre il ne voulait pas que la technique
entrave sa créativité et c'est pour ça
qu'il va tourner en extérieur c'est des
cigales et ben c'est la vie c'est comme
ça c'est le bruit des voitures c'est la
vie c'est comme ça il voulait que son
texte cool
il ne voulait aucun artifice il ne
croyait pas en l'esthétique pour
l'esthétique pour lui le film c'était
avant tout le fond et donc le dialogue
alors dialogue mais des acteurs parce
que tout à l'heure on n'a pas on n'a
même pas par le raimu qu'une rencontre
considérable mais ya une deuxième
rencontre extraordinaire qu'est
fernandel ferme fernandel qu'il
rencontre je crois en 34 38 34 et
qu'il va qui va tout de suite donné le
premier rôle d'angel enfin un grand rôle
dans gêne angèle fernandel à l'époque
était connu comme un comique troupier
n'a peu comme rémy aussi à l'époque et
marcel tout de suite va déceler chez eux
de grand talent dramatique alors le
sprint comment ça c'est un film assez
extraordinaire oui mais déjà le tournage
en lui-même est extraordinaire parce que
le squeeze c'est un est un cover 7 de
regain c'est à dire que regard est
tourné en extérieur dans les collines et
quand il pleut marcel à ses studios à
marseille à 20 km quand il pleut dans la
tournée le schpountz en studio dans la
même journée le matin on peut tourner
regain et l'après midi le schpountz avec
les mêmes comédiens train tout le monde
se mélange et dans les costumes d'antan
dans tout ça quoi alors il ya une
période rang qui était un peu difficile
c'est la période de l'occupation la
fille du puisatier où il a été obligé de
composer avec la censure allemande ce
qui lui a valu des ennuis à la
libération
effectivement donc il est en plein
tournage de la fille du puisatier et les
allemands lui propose de prendre la tête
de la continental donc la société de
propagande cinématographique allemande
et lui ne veut pas mais il est quand
même à la tête des studios de sa société
de production de distribution de cinéma
s'il refuse des allemands vont tous
fermés par l'intermédiaire de vichy s'il
accepte il trahit ses idéaux non qu'il
vente ou sont tout son affaire à gaumont
et il va acheter
un domaine horticole dans les eaux de
nice dans les hauteurs de nice pour
faire des éoliennes
exactement c'est comme ça qui va
apprendre comment on fait des oeillets
il en parlera dans manon il se nourrit
toujours de sa vie comme tous les
auteurs tous les artistes et il va
accueillir dans cette propriété
certains de ces de ses employés en leur
faisant des certificats de travailleurs
de force pour les soustraire au st lô
pareil à la buzine son père habite
pendant cette période
donc il va passer la guerre la guerre
jusqu'en 1940 43 il va il va rester au
domaine de l'étoile horticulteurs alors
jacqueline faut parler de la rencontre
avec jacqueline puisque jacqueline c'est
la fin de ces femmes de sa vie est en
tout cas il a rencontré à la 24 ans il
en a qu'il en a 49 il la rencontre la
première fois en 1838 elle a 17 ans il
peut passer une audition pour un court
métrage qu'on ne sera pas tournée et ben
je pense qu'on remontant à paris douala
repenser l je me sens même s'il n'a pas
vu sur une affiche parce que je joue au
théâtre il va la voir et se quitteront
plus jamais il part avec elle dans son
moulin de parcé sur sarthe qu'il avait
acquis en 1932 et ils vont attendre la
libération là bas ils voient arriver les
américains et ils se marient ce mari dès
1944 et en 46 ligne est quelqu'un qui
vous importe ma oui mon père frédéric
oui dans leur premier enfant
c'est l'année 46 ski vraiment une année
charnière
il est élu à l'académie française rémy
moeurs et il a mon père donc qui on a
vraiment là les joies et les peines et 7
pour moi cette année c'est vraiment la
bascule dans la vie de mon grand-père et
et bien sa carrière cinématographique va
changer les choses
après guerre ne seront plus jamais les
mêmes qu'avant guerre parce qu'il n'a
plus son indépendance totale alors on
danse y est aussi allé voilà il va pas
une tournée n'assiste pas énormément de
films manon des sources et jean de
florette
mais on sent que quelque chose s'est
brisé en lui quelque chose a changé
je suis intimement persuadé qu'il a
recommencé à tourner pour ma grand mère
voilà voilà
alors jusqu'à la fameuse partie de
cartes cette scène qui est un
chef-d'oeuvre universel maintenant alors
c'était
lors de la création de marius ou à côté
à 30,29 effectivement mars elle avait
supprimé la partie de cartes parce que
c'était un sketch écrit pour laisser
libre cours aux numéros de cabotinage de
raimu et de et de charpin il décide de
la coupée et tous les acteurs 120 lui
dire la répète le soir de la première
il la joue et c'est un triomphe et mars
est encore émue arrive dans sa loge sur
le papier peint écrit au feutre enfin
vos crayons de maquillage est écrit
monsieur raimu est un génie ce c'était
donc mon grand père qui avait écrit et
raimu à découper un morceau de papier
peint et la garder dans son bureau toute
sa vie il est d'ailleurs au musée raimu
à cogolin toujours pour les poupons peut
le voir mais la fin de sa vie alors
comment on vous la raconter ou comment
vous l'avez vécue si je puis dire la fin
de sa vie alors je passerai à une autre
période avant de passer à la fin je
dirais pourquoi at il arrêté le cinéma
c'est la perte de sa fille estelle c'est
les conditions de tournage qui
deviennent de plus en plus compliquée la
profession se professionnalise si je
puis dire et du vin très difficile pour
lui de tourner et donc il va continuer à
créer mais devant une page blanche se
passer la voir de mon père c'est manon
des sources
d'abord elle il faut ouvrir bien
rappeler que ça d'abord été un
feuilleton mais des souvenirs d'enfance
dans l est que ça a eu un tel succès
qu'il en a fait les ouvrages par des
doutes ces trois et même quatre oui la
gloire de mon père le château de ma mère
le temps des secrets le temps des amours
d'un cio effectivement hélène lazareff
pendant le dîner qui m'écoutent marcel
tu n'as jamais rien écrit pour moi pour
pour elle et lui dit pas de problème je
te livre ça très bientôt
et elle a appelé tous les jours et lui
n'avaient pas écrit une ligne quand elle
lui a envoyé un coursier en vélo et
quand ce conseil une demande des six
pages
qui lui avait promis il dit mais je les
ai pas pensé mais moi si je reviens sans
équipage me fait mettre à la porte est
donc en 20 minutes il a écrit des six
premières pages du château de ma mère
qui a commencé par le château de ma mère
est tout de suite a été un grand succès
pour les lecteurs de lé voilà donc qui
s'est levé vendu ddd 20 millions
d'exemplaires de ses livres sa fin et
peut être résumée peut-être savidan dans
cette épitaphe
il a aimé sa femme ses amis et les
sources
je vous remercie à nicolas pagnol
alors on lira bien sûr jean jacques
gillot blanc pagnol inconnue c'est dans
les grandes biographies flammarion et on
attend avec impatience votre livre
nicolas pagnol ce bolide sur marcel
pagnol l'album d'une vie ce sera
également chez flammarion
nicolas pagnol merci vraiment beaucoup
d'avoir fait revivre marseille pour nous
merci
[Musique]